los salvadoreños votaron este domingo
para renovar congresos y municipalidades
es unas elecciones que son cruciales
para el presidente en equipo que después
le permitiría consolidar su poder a
través de una victoria que es lo que
reflejaron los diferentes sondeos de
opinión que se realizaron por distintas
casas encuestadoras fueron un total de
10 partidos los que participaron en esta
elección sin embargo todo apunta que
perdería el control la oposición de la
asamblea legislativa tanto la alianza
republicana nacionalista arena de
derecha y la izquierda del frente
farabundo martí para la liberación
nacional fueron 1.500 centros de
votación
unos bueno yo estuve en el mayor centro
de votación de la capital y éste
aperturó hasta con dos horas de retraso
lo que provocó
que la gente manifestara ciertas
molestias incluso el mismo presidente
tuiteó denunciando al tribunal supremo
electoral por este atraso